c'est complètement délirant et c'est
évidemment une utilisation très
intéressante pourquoi ce débat ce soir
parce que moi pour moi il ya une
minorité de privilégiés en france ils
ont globalement fermer des usines en
france
ils ont fait baisser les salaires ils
ont fait venir au ici des gens qu'ils
sous payent parce que la plupart du
temps les migrants ne sont pas déclarés
n'accepte pas sur les links qu'on
fabrique on est bien se passer
c'est le coeur du sujet non non le
business est un livre pour l'arrivée des
lakers à bloc qui le business il aurait
privilégié à faire croire qu'il ya du
racisme d'une part et d'autre part à
exciter les différences et les haines
entre les gens ce sondage sert à ça le
jdd et la pravda de macron monsieur
belattar était le bouffon du roi il a
servi macron ça va dans le bon sens
accepter de voter pour lui non mais
guillaume bigot c'est pas le débat
deuxième si c'est des journées des
macros le sec sur ses news un long
tunnel où vous dites que de la merde moi
ici je dois vous répondre 1 2 vous
porter très bien votre nom je vais vous
dire le 3e prouve hélas et j'essaie de
mails faveur niveau si vous insultez
parce que visiblement la regarde et bien
d'autres ne la regardez ce que celle
regard et une volée haute estime et à la
brouille née pour faire venir regarder
les français pour faire un et garder les
bois ironisé sur les naucellois hier
dernier à leur vie
bien répondre mais regardez à la fois la
mère dit que mon nom je pas bien mon nom
mais regardez il faut dire la vérité aux
populations
ouais vous là moi je viens c'est alors
oui c'est vrai que c'est le beauf et
déjà genou font de personnes et
deuxièmement me traiter de bata
objectivement je vous ai max était le
batteur vous m'avez dit que je portais
bien vidéo je peux finir dit que c'était
aussi malin je peux feu de dire que je
me fournis en prime avec bâtard je
venais me convient c'est quoi sinon s'il
vous plaît non mais c'est quoi
l'epita leur gentil donc c'est
l'autoroute écoute son nom mais a déjà
faut pas me tutoyez je suis pas votre
chauffeur et escarres d'étudier ans un
des diamants je crois que vous aurez
déjà mais voulait parler tous hermine et
yacine non mais objectivement vous êtes
là vous faites partie où je vous écoute
mais vous êtes présidentiable vous êtes
là depuis tout à l'heure
là les français vous venez de leur
donner un exemple que ceux de cette
émission peut souligner c'est que les
racailles sont pas du côté où l'on pense
vous insultez vous provoquez vous êtes
là vous n'êtes même pas capable de vous
remettre en question aujourd'hui quand
vous commencez votre intitulé attendait
quand vous commencez votre intitulé par
le fait de faire croire oui je connais
le présent la république ça vous pose un
problème
est ce que ça vous pose un problème biko
parce que c'est un problème bruit
problème c'est parce que attendez je
vais au bout de ma phrase savoureuse et
une action jouée avec l'arabe et les
noirs de ce pays qui sont français qui
porte la fierté d'être français tous les
jours tant tous tout en ayant une
culture annexes qui leur permet de
croire en un dieu ou non une culture
vous pose problème la réponse est oui
la caravane garder ce que vous faites
tous les jours sur ses news allez on
réponde à nos places et ensuite pour
alain vanhée là je voudrais pas vous
voudrez envers un particulier ou poser
une question à poser des questions et
vous rêvez d'aller battre les minimes
l'aimé pour que l'on me voit son pari
osé mais qui paraît ce que vous êtes en
terrain conquis là vous allez faire
la parole et c'est guillaume de quoi
vous parlons maintenant mais ses goûts
ses agents des pistes moi j'aimerais
comprendre qu'alizé la parole à des gens
qui viennent sur ce plateau
quand c'est pas jean messia c'est bingo
qui passent leur vie à venir sur un
plateau parce que c'est des anneaux et
la première fois pour évoquer dernière
oui ça nous a fait chaud ce truc qui je
nous ai deja et c'est bon l'autorité
vous réclamez rêver le monde rien de
pitt alors j'essaie de parler vous êtes
là vous essayé de me pousser à bout
je vais pas vous faire quoi que ce soit
je vous dis en face de moi que personne
ne vous connais vous êtes personnes et
qu'aujourd'hui pour utiliser un discours
qui fait parler les beaucoup de gens ici
on a pas comment j'ai des potes
désaccord avec plein de chroniqueurs que
les choses soient bien claires mais ça
nous empêche pas d'avoir un but commun
c'est que le fait que les gens puissent
vivre ensemble dans un pays qui porte
soit 165 millions de personnes